The joe rogan experience.
Have you bravo.
What's happening?
Cock sucker.
What's up?
You're a month away from having a kid.
You sitting there like fucking
Buddha with no fucking food.
Talk to me.
I love ready for this man.
Are you ready?
This you gotta be fucking ready.
Oh Tommy Shit.
Hell yeah.
You gotta be ready.
Have you picked a name yet?
You looked at t a TV show on discovery.
I want you to tell me you went the uncle's
house and change some diapers and a
habit for awhile.
And we tried that.
This was planned.
This was not an accident.
I wanted a kid.
I want her to kid.
You know,
I'm proud of you.
I'm happy if it's going to
be a fascinating experience.
Man
were different.
Fucking men for sure
changed me as a human being.
First it was the refund when you came
to me and you said you had the best ice
cream Sundae in your life.
Whenever you bravo the
way you gave it to me.
That was beautiful.
And then next thing you know,
Mrs Rogan came on the scene.
I seem to hold up that I will never
forget the day Eddie Bravo got me high.
We that we went and had ice cream Sundae
and I had the most massive revelation
in my life.
I couldn't believe how God damn good.
That ice cream Sundae a bit.
Your menu was the first time we ever
straightened up before then you were
fucking ape.
You were still bent over.
If I drew you a banana,
you need to fucking pill.
Seriously.
Dairy Queen,
you were back.
You were back.
Your chest is up his shit.
Well you guys know me.
I don't know me as well as you guys know.
Please.
That was it.
You were walking on all snow until
that fucking drama from person.
I'm a lot more relaxed and everything,
but it must've been interesting.
Much more for you to watch
someone changed their first.
So fucking beautiful vain man.
I love to see evolution.
I,
but people watch it.
I love to watch people
shut your fucking mouth.
Don't say to him,
let him walk into that hole.
You know?
Don't say that,
but think coming from,
you know,
my background,
but like doing martial arts competitions
my whole life and then just transition
right into comedy.
I had never relaxed.
I never settled down.
I never,
I never learned how to just be calm,
you know?
It was my whole body and my brain,
my personality,
all developed under duress.
It all developed under a physical
combat all the time on a regular basis.
Constant training,
constant fights,
constant tournament's that was,
no,
that was my life from like the time I
was 15 till I was 22 all my formative
years was all spent in,
in stress.
And I remember when I first decided
that I wasn't going to fight anymore.
I was like the first time ever in my
life when I was like 22 it's my last
kickboxing fights.
The first time ever where I could relax,
I would always like be nervous.
Like when is the next tournament?
When's the next fight?
When's the next thing
I got to get in shape?
I can't be drinking this.
I can't be doing this.
Couldn't live my life because I was always
worried about getting my ass kicked.
I was always worrying about like,
I have to make sure that
I do everything right.
I had to be prepared.
I don't want to get fucked up,
you know?
So it's like,
it's,
it wasn't the best mindset to
go into stand up comedy for,
that's for sure.
It's like a constant battle
because standup comedy,
you got to,
it's totally the opposite.
You've got to not give a fuck.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta be relaxed.
You've got to have fun instead of be
tense and ready to go at any moment's
notice.
You know,
you sent me a,
by the way,
whatever you sent me,
it doesn't work.
One of them doesn't work.
The other two do.
Check her emails.
You sent me two things and both of them
are like movies that are one second long
what?
Yeah.
It's amazing how again,
dude,
I know it's,
I know.
It's good.
My father,
he send it.
Okay.
I fucking 15 to 22 my mind
wasn't fighting the Ma.
I was a fighter,
but I was in a different type of hell.
I was in my own hall.
I was putting myself into,
you know,
it was so weird.
I became a comic,
what,
six,
seven,
eight years later or something like that
and how I took that wildness into the
fucking comic and nobody understood what
I was saying until I met you guys at
the store.
I filed the fucking home.
I was always,
I used to travel on the road with
Dribbble and to all these little road.
Dot.
I remember when I first
met you at the store,
everybody was fucking terrified of you.
Yeah,
I was crazy and I was letting you,
you and I,
I remember being like the only guy,
like when I first met you that was like,
he's great.
What are you talking about?
I love that guy.
And he was like,
Oh,
here comes Joey Diaz.
Like,
where's he at?
I like what gravitate towards
you because you didn't scare me.
You were nice to me.
You were you,
you weren't a scary guy to me.
You were a regular dude.
I see.
You were like one of the only
guys there that I could relate to.
There was like a lot of guys
that I couldn't relate to.
I knew dudes like you,
you know,
I mean,
not you,
but you and my friend
Johnny be the Pool Hustler.
Very similar characters,
man.
Very,
very similar characters.
You're both way out there.
You both like not give a fuck guys.
And you're both guys that
were like polarizing.
Some people would love you
to death and then everybody,
you know,
there was a lot,
a large group of people
that for whatever reason,
they'd be upset at you.
Like,
I remember having to defend you,
even a dom Arrera,
even.
Dot.
Merera was hate nine year for everybody.
Every and I don't get,
and I loved it.
I fucking loved it because that's what I,
you know,
it's so weird that this whole surgery
thing really taught me about fear.
My fear has fucking done wonders for me
because that's why when I wake up in the
molest,
the first thing I stopped him
do is grab my fucking cock.
Because for years I was scared.
I'm always insecure that immigrant fucking
things shizzle into my fucking mind.
Since the streets in New
York City with the White Kid,
the immigrant thing,
not knowing the language,
not feeling good enough
like everybody else,
not being a fucking American and
it sits inside my fucking soul.
So for me,
everything has been ribbon on fear.
Every time I get on stage,
it's like the other night
fear was real in Chicago.
I got on stage in between the reefer and
whatever was going on and the lights.
I got fearful man,
but you know what?
That's normal to be scared.
That's a great emotion,
especially when you're a standup comic,
because when go,
the more schedule,
the better you're going to fucking do.
Especially in my case,
the more riled up I am.
Two minutes before I go on stage,
the more energy I'm going to
give that fucking audience.
But I've looked at my life and I've seen
how much fear I was petrified to go get
that fucking needle,
even though I fucking knew
nothing was going to happen.
I was going to walk out of there,
but I went in,
I took the needle after I
walked out of that and be like,
could have fucking killed 10 fucking
people with my bare hands because you
overcome one of your
biggest fucking fears.
Till this day I get
little emails and people,
you know,
I suffer,
I suffer from a social disorder and I
don't know what to do with the answer and
taking a fucking pill.
It's checking your fucking confidence and
grabbing your balls and walking into a
circle and saying,
fuck it.
I'm here.
You know,
my mentality was always go into little
mouth of the lion and put a chair down
and sit the fuck down and let
the pieces fall where they may.
And if you're not going to live like that,
fuck them more.
I'm at the store too.
Fucking nights.
Joe Rogan,
the first fucking night
Eddie Griffin bumps me.
You know how embarrassing it is?
You become a regular on a Sunday,
the first fucking night you let
bring 11 people that come see you,
your landlord comes and you
get bumped by Eddie Griffin.
And the second night I grew up getting,
Steve Greenstein says to me,
Hey,
last weekend you fucking
audition here for Mitson.
You said,
one of my jokes.
I said,
it's February fucking 11 I just come off
a plane January 29 and you're already
accusing me of being a fucking thief.
And remember he had his violin case.
Who?
Steve Greenstein,
I don't remember if it was a creepy guy,
older guy hanging out at the comedy store.
He had a violin case.
So this is a Tuesday night.
It's Black Knight at the comedy store.
It's eight o'clock.
The main room was packed with the original
room BMP because people were scared
to go up there and black knight because
they thought they were going to get
fucking mug.
So the original room was always empty.
So Steve Greenstein was up before me.
He get,
this is my second mentor comedies.
Good dog.
I just got to La.
I'm a fucking criminal.
I'd been in prison.
I got all these problems.
But for a first time my life,
I got a little fucking daylight,
the county store.
This lady made me a regular.
All my life.
People were like,
cause Mitzi shore seeing
you as Mitzi shore seen you.
She going to make your fucking regular.
I get down there,
I'm a regular is the first time
since my mother died a holiday look,
I had been in prison,
I had been divorced,
you know,
shot the whole fucking deal and the next
thing you know I become a regular is
Tuesday night and I get off stage and
I'm waiting to hang out for a little
while.
And Steve Greenstein comes
up to me and he says to me,
dog,
one of your jokes is like my joke.
I said,
which one?
He said something about Oj Simpson's May.
I got dog.
I didn't steal the joke from me.
I just fucking got here two weeks ago.
Wheels comes out,
he goes,
this guy,
that is still the joke from you.
The only problem was the guy put the
violin case behind this fucking legs and I
spotted it.
So he starts threatening me.
He's like dogs.
The next time you do their job,
we're going to have a problem.
I just pushed him.
Joe Rogan,
he fell over the violin case.
Why has he's fallen down.
Mitsis Limo pulls up.
That's it.
I'm like,
I'm done.
This is my life.
I'm fucking gun out of here.
I'm never going to get
another fucking spot again.
I'm going to go back to
selling and fucking blow and
wheels got between US Scott
Day gap between us and Mitzi came and go,
ah,
what happened here?
And he started saying that.
He goes,
no,
this kid's Cuban but bravado and but Mitzi
seen the kid on the floor and fell in
love with me after that cause
I had pushed that motherfucker.
She liked it cause I skipped
something from myself.
Sure.
You get lucky.
She was crazy.
She liked dark.
If that happened at the fuck and Improv,
I would have been out
on the fucking street.
How often did you perform at
the Improv and those days?
In those days?
Every week.
Because the Guy Richard Cooper loved me,
the talent coordinator.
But I got to La January 29th
that was a regular at the store.
February 19th on my birthday.
I didn't fuck around this
down when I got here,
but you couldn't do the
Improv and Mitzi found out.
But I went to Scott Bass had dog.
Richard Cooper gives me spots.
So I would go over there and I
had a couple problems over there.
Right off the fucking bat.
People thought they were cute over there.
You know,
you,
you leave your fucking
girlfriend and a seat,
you're going to baton,
you come back and talk.
And so I'm like,
they know that is an issue.
No,
it's a fucking issue.
You got to,
you got to stop.
I'm like,
I told you like Hitler
in Munich or if not,
you're going to have
a fucking problem dog.
So I would say things to people and all
of a sudden you're a bad fucking person.
So what the fuck?
I don't give a fuck.
And when he at 12 years later and
we're still rocking and rolling,
they can still suck my
dick and call me shorty.
[inaudible]
okay.